whoa whoa whoa season three of sunny
family cult on [ __ ] tv gets
crazy if you want to hear all the hidden
details about the big connection between
looksy and sunny family cult
then what you're going to want to do is
watch this whole video from start
to finish this video is sponsored by
[ __ ] tv
[Music]
sunny family cult is back and it picks
up right where season 2 left off with
taylor being driven
into the desert which confused me a bit
because i always thought they lived in
iowa there's actually an answer to this
question of how they end up in the
desert in a now
unlisted miniseries called rogers vlog
which takes place between season 2
and season 3 and can only be found by
looking through the playlist section on
crip's channel
let's check it out
my dad won't stop until he finds oh i
believe that
absolutely but luckily
we've got four states in between him and
us so
we're farther away from iowa than he's
ever been in his entire life
which puts them in california now
roger's vlog doesn't exactly go up with
casey neistat levels of consistency but
we do get a little more information
in the second and at the time of making
this final vlog
when i started this call about 20 years
ago my brother didn't realize it's
significant
he didn't see that there was crazy you
think that you started the sunny family
cult
people have been talking about sunny
family for like
30 years since like the 80s
the town's full of stories yes there was
a cult
back in the 80s but it was not the sunny
family cult that i started
this confirms what i predicted in my
last things you missed on sunny family
cult seasons one and two
about how roger's chapter of the cult
branches off from the original
so after driving halfway across the
country they end up in a motel in the
california desert but after attempting
to escape and getting a couple innocent
people chopped up by roger taylor finds
herself tied up in the motel room
now we're bringing chaos into the world
to show people what is really important
it's time to wipe it clean
start over
so as i mentioned before roger's chapter
of the cult is the antithesis
of elias's chapter and many of the
flashback scenes here in season three
show how that divide was formed this
line really spells out exactly how the
two values differ
it's mentioned from the very beginning
how the purpose of elias's cult is to
introduce chaos and disrupt bonaldi can
we introduce chaos
to disrupt the banality of this life and
in season 3 we get to see exactly why
those values are adopted
taylor of course being someone who has
grown up learning the ways of elias is
naturally repulsed by roger's ideas
and has this to say about him you're a
monster no i'm not
i need you for that that line leads us
into the main plot of this season
rogers conquest to fulfill the ritual
from this ancient book he found we get a
little more of that book in episode two
and it is filled with things you missed
this is the first page that we get a
good look at and a closer inspection
reveals that it's all about
looksie the latin text tempus edx rerun
translates into time devourer of all
things that of course ties into looxi's
iconic accessory his stopwatch
there's also a clock present on this
page a sketch of looksie's hand and
mouth and the act of looksie taking a
body part in this case the face from
someone who was not able to release
there's also a much deeper possible
connection with looksie that i'll touch
back on
later in this video the next page looks
to be about suit the newest crypt tv
serialization
directed by my very talented friend
danny donoghue
there's only one episode of suit out so
far but the tagline is
every cycle must be completed and the
episode seems to compare the cycles of
electricity
to life cycles the latin on the page to
the right contains the phrases he began
to perish
and difficult for those in the highest
something that's where it cuts off the
text also mentions something about
selection
and there's an image of a human eye i'm
sure we'll find out more about how all
of that ties into the themes of the
series
very soon the next page doesn't have any
legible text but it does contain the
symbol of the birch
the most popular short film on [ __ ] tv
which will also be serialized in the
near future
there's also a page on this cursed
statue from another recent crypt series
stone heart the latin on the left page
says something about a sacred dance
though i can't make out much more than
that and the english on the right reads
for she the protector
will strike down all that oppose those
that would denounce her name
one for the stones the man cast will
break the bones of his enemies
she seeks to redress that wrong come to
her and she will end
all your pain all your and that's where
it cuts off the next page is a bit more
ambiguous but it shows what appears to
be a pony the main witch from stoneheart
and moreover this is just a really cool
illustration
moving on the symbols on the left here
are not anything that i'm familiar with
but if anyone has any leads on how to
decipher them
please let me know in the comments i'm
sure you're all familiar with the sunny
family cult symbol but what you may have
missed is when roger moves his hand
the shadow of another new creature can
be seen very briefly before roger turns
the page once again and
this is an important one because it
details the ritual that becomes the
centerpiece of everything roger is
aiming for
in the season of sunny fam the whole
reason roger kidnaps taylor is because
he believes
she's the one who can help him unlock
this hidden power
she's the girl of 17 with violence
etched into her soul with dark hair and
dark eyes pictured at the center here in
this book and these monsters drawn above
a pony mordio and looksy all existing
crypt creatures are examples of what
kind of monsters might be created from
carrying out this ritual
the diagram outlines five sacrifices and
the caption calls for
a blood sacrifice of four victims and
the fifth will become something the
other side details what i can only
imagine is the transformation process
from man
to monster so after taking all of these
pages in roger looks up to see a vision
of this girl this shot is very
reminiscent from an image from one of
the lesser known crypt short films the
woman in the book where not much
background is given about the story but
a similar looking creepy lady seems to
be summoned from a book in that short as
well
mr sandman also features a similar book
so the idea of crypt lore being hidden
in ancient texts has been established
even before
sunny family cult now at this point at
the end of the second episode of season
three
you could chalk up all of these
references to other crypt properties to
be nothing more than
fun easter eggs but going forward in
episode 3 it becomes very clear that all
of these worlds are destined to collide
in
sunny family cult
if you're enjoying the video so far
you've probably noticed this stylish
attire
if you want to be part of the sunny fam
you've got to have
this merge and there's only one way to
get it all you have to do is sign up for
the crypt newsletter using the link in
the description and you'll be in the
know about their exclusive
monthly merch drops now back to things
you missed remember back in season two
when taylor and jaina are being chased
by the masked roger and taylor asked
jaina if she can see him too
basically suggesting that she's been
having hallucinations you can see it too
what if those visions tie into taylor's
status as the chosen girl in the
prophecy of roger's book
the third episode begins with a pair of
hands that should be familiar to anyone
who's seen looksy attacking taylor in
her sleep
she wakes up back in her room where she
sees yet another monster rise up before
her based on the shadow on the wall it
looks like a pony
but this is also just a dream as this
episode progresses it becomes
more and more clear that these are more
than just references sunny family cult
is the epicenter of a [ __ ] tv
cinematic universe including all of
their monster properties
the hashtag monster within is more than
just a catchy tagline
in this crypt universe there's a monster
within all of us
waiting to be unleashed by this ancient
ritual roger's buying into all of it
he's gone and got a tattoo with a sunny
family called logo at the center the
cursed statue from stoneheart
looksy suit and the stick symbol from
the birch all of these icons have risen
up from the girl making
the final sacrifice as roger tries to
convince taylor to take part he tells
her the following
we can do this together we can wipe away
what we hate
in this world this is an interesting
take because roger believes
he's the good guy and in the end he
might be looksie
mordio a pony the birch all of their
victims tend to be
criminals bad people or people with
dangerous flaws
if that's what you call a monster
then yes we will turn ourselves
into monsters taylor of course thinks
this is insane and gets the heck out of
there taking refuge in the motel
manager's office
unfortunately for her roger has been
there already for those of you keeping
count at home
i know at least one of you is that's
three kills at the motel
taylor uses his fingerprint to unlock
his phone and call her dad who by the
way has a north carolina area code i
guess what roger said about him
never having ventured this far from iowa
is still true that is
until episode 4 the season finale
it is at this point that we finally see
the face of the girl from roger's
visions and it looks
exactly like taylor a rush of images
flash on screen very quickly
looksy the cursed statue from stoneheart
troubled youth suit mordio a pony
the famous monster from the birch
taylor's dad showing up
ends up working in roger's favor because
he unknowingly
becomes the fourth sacrifice at the
motel it is as it is
written in the book four blood
sacrifices and the fifth
will become something taylor's anger
gets the better of her and she gives
roger
exactly what he wants making him the
fifth sacrifice
and ending the season on his revival
i'm excited to see whatever monster
roger becomes in the next season because
whatever it is it really becomes the
biggest boss in all of kryptv canon the
bad guy
that presides over all other bad guys on
the crypt channel
the one that brings each series together
into one
this is a really exciting time to be a
follower of the sunny family cult
and the crypt channel in general there
are series within the cinematic universe
airing right now and you don't want to
miss out so make sure you subscribe to
kryptv for scary episodes every tuesday
thursday and friday and i'll see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive